This small country star behind me with a customary crowd of idlers on the front porch or stoop as the South Africans call it
might be found in any small Rural American community
But the dirt road that runs parallel to this small country store marks the beginning of a location in the town of [Nelspruit]
the African location where natives are forced to live
Nelle Spirit a small mining town in the northern Transvaal has for the past week been the focus of the racial tension in South Africa
It started with a protest march by some 400 native women on the police station
the women have long been more militant in their resistance to apartheid laws in South Africa than have been their Menfolk and
In nell's break this week the African woman has suddenly become the focal point of resistance to the nationalist government
Now sprayed on the surface this rainy humid day looks as quiet as that scene on that rustic front porch of the storm
But in reality [nell] spray is still tense after a week of trouble big trouble and violence even in South Africa [I]
Asked for permission this morning to go inside the location at [nell] Spricht and make this film
We were told that there has been trouble there lately, and they'd rather not have any Europeans go inside
This then is our next recourse
What is behind the firm continued refusal of African women to accept passes well?
the process have been enforced in South Africa for award very long time among the main and
It has become very clear that the [pass] system in South Africa is the basis of forced and cheap labor
Now to impose such a system up only African women is to create hardships
firstly
African women will have to produce these passes on demand if they fail to do [so] they will be arrested in the streets
They will be stopped at stations
They will be stopped as they visit one another in the locations, and if they haven't got those passes
They will be stopped and immediately arrested and brought before the court now African men
Who value they are women just as any other people [they] olivia women say what will happen to their children?
Ladies, why was the black sash formed in the first place [well] the black sash was formed in the [first] place because the nationalist government?
introduced the senate bill into parliament
It was a bill to expand the size of the senate to almost double the [size] of its
Original size and you fear that this would do one
Well we felt that it was a legal
trick or we didn't know whether it was legal then but we [felt] it was a piece of trickery and
against the spirit of the Constitution
What has been the official government reaction to your?
protests of [mourning]
the
Government have ridiculed us for mourning. They don't understand or say they don't understand why women should stand
mourning a constitution they think we would be much better staying at home and looking after our children and
Obviously you won't disagree. Well. We think that we do look after our children
We feel [very] much that this is looking after our children because after all it's the future of our children. We're worried about
If I had no children, I don't think my interest would be nearly as keen
in this connection
it's been said that the South African woman the white woman occupies a
privileged position in the world because of the abundance of servants and cheap labor here
Wouldn't this somehow conflict with what you're trying to do arouse women to protest?
Yes, it does. I [think] that we [are] very privileged women in that. We are not tied to the kitchen sink because
As with so many women are [in] other parts of the world
And I think that is all the more reason why women should play their full part in
The duties of an individual in a democracy we feel that democracy cannot work unless
every individual knows what her
Obligations are in the democracy
But I think you're putting the standard of morals very low if you reckon that we are going to go on supporting [our] [party] just
in order to keep [our] servants
One final question
Being very realistic. How soon can you hope to take off that black sash?
Well, I'm afraid not in our lifetime
By far the largest church denomination in the Union of South Africa is the dutch
reformed church with a membership of almost two million white and non-white members
With us this morning is Domini Adrienne Berger
secretary of the Federal council of Dutch reformed churches and editor of [Diva] [lector] the Transvaal church magazine
Domine [berger] you [believed] in apartheid as a way of life. Yes. I do [why] in South Africa. Why is that sir?
because the race which is in this estate of development is by far in the majority had and
numerically of course they are much stronger and
Because also, I believe that it is according to God's will
that the white Race
Which is in the majority in this country?
Should be preserved and also everything we have done in the last 300 years and built up
in the church and in the state should [be] preserved and not
be swallowed up by and I
wouldn't say in theory a race because [it] I don't believe it is an inferior race, but a lesser a
Race which is in a lesser state of development. That's all
you sir have been fighting a fight for a long time that requires as I see it a
great deal of quiet sustained courage
Don't you ever have [a] sense of futility of uselessness? Well there come times of course when one does feel that?
You're frustrated in what you're trying to do it yet on the other hand. There's a great thrill in it
Perhaps you can answer this one question that's intrigued me for a long time
There are [I] am sure devout believers in apartheid were also devout Christians
Can these two apart [hating] Christianity in Europe in yin be reconciled? I'm quite sure that they cannot
One of the mystifying things to me is how anybody who claims to be a Christian can be a disciple of apartheid?
do you find any conflict between apartheid and
Christianity
no, certainly not as a matter of fact our dutch reformed churches are doing much more for
The Christianization of this of the non-white people in this country than any other protestant [church]
in this country and anywhere in Africa
We as Christians believe
in the
development of the non-white people and we certainly
Try to develop them as far as possible by building their churches giving
subsidizing them in their church work, and we are also trying to
Give them leadership where they want it and our
Experience is that these people prefer to [be] left in their own churches as a matter of fact there are nine different
[non] white churches
belonging to the dutch reformed church amongst the non-white people and
they prefer that there are instances when we come together on a higher level in conferences and
sometimes also in their churches
we often come there as white people to visit them and
There are also instances where we even have communion with him can you foresee any eventual end to apartheid in the dutch reformed church?
the Dutch Japan Church
Does not practice [apothic] because we believe that
Integration is
Religiously around or ethically wrong certainly not in theory we have nothing against integration
It's only a matter of tickle policy in this country now for this
For this moment if conditions should change
This or any other practical policy could also be changed something
Is there any corollary do you think between American segregation and South African apartheid?
No, I think
Well in one sense. I think it's all part [of] a royal pattern [I]
Think that the white race as a whole find it extremely difficult to realize that they can no longer dominate the whole world
But the thing [that] encouraged me in America
Is that in spite of what has [happened] that is happening the general trend is in entirely the opposite Direction
What is happening in South Africa?
The user [believed] that there's any possibility now or in the immediate foreseeable future of large-scale violence in South Africa
No, there are a lot of people who seem to be very fearful that it may happen, but for my part
I am convinced that all the responsible leadership
Of the India among the Africans and Indians is determined at all cost to
prevent violence if they can possibly do so
Mr.. Prince, Lil. What is the basic philosophy underlying?
Apartheid as a way of life we europeans. [who've] lived in this country for more than 300 years
Have come to a conclusion
Which is strange to some people in the western world namely that the peoples of Africa and so the bunch of people of South Africa?
Have a beautiful civilization of their own which is worth preserving
There are many facets of the civilization for instance the social warmth of the bantu people's
Which we westerners can rightly envy them now
We also have a peculiar waste and adaptation to Africa
Therefore we can say that the bonded peoples are a flower and the western peoples are a flower each
With a beauty of its own
I've heard them in the South Africa of today
You can be classified as coloured simply by looking colored is this in point of fact true
Well, I can give you [a] better
Which may seem amusing that all the humiliating incidents had occurred in our country?
when the department of
census started to declassifying people
the old people of the times in [the] mornings out of the bus queues and took him up [to] the native commissioner's office and
some of the tits applied
To tell a man that he was not colored was trying to profit from [3za] and the [comstock] [is] told you at Keffer
and
Other people lose [know] this with a bit flat
But older you're not a colored
[Mister] [Prinsloo] [as] you are no doubt aware
Most Criticism of apartheid outside the Union is based largely on Moral grounds
For example the morality of separate residential areas in the cities [of] the Union pass laws lack of voting rights and so on
How would you reply to lists as far as residential areas are concerned the practical
Situation is that until about [ten] years ago there were no
Residential areas for Urban bunch of people it is only in the last Few [years] that
Such areas were set aside on a plan basis
and developed at a terrific pace as you can see all around you this housing scheme which now houses more than
30,000 urban Bantu who work in Victoria was at their [plain] a mere four years ago
I think that is a complete answer [to] the so-called immorality of separate
residential areas in the political field we are creating an
Outlet in that we are proclaiming bon to authorities in all the major
Boundary areas of the Union we have already
Brought into life more than three hundred such authorities where one two who have the inclination?
the training and the Moral courage
to start developing their own people can do so with all possible assistance from the government if
the government
Convinced that the African wants and accepts apartheid as a development policy
for Obvious reasons many opponents of this policy tried to influence the bunch of people in the other direction and
like all new philosophies like all new piece [of]
Policies we had to put our case to the bunch of people and I can safely say today that the bantu
People are accepting the policy of self-development
[which] essentially is a part with a part it essentially is in an ever increasing [temple]
I feel confident that the Bantu leadership of Africa
rural and Urban
Will by the turn of next year show in a most market way that they are satisfied that this policy
leads to their salvation
Is to knock way Mr.. Prince lou of the native affairs department?
Told me in pretoria this week that the African accepts and wants apartheid as a stage of development you
[Sir] agree well
It's a privileged information in mind, and I can claim to be slightly more informed than Mr.
Prince [knows] because I live among the African and I am an African
[cannot] be quite correct at all the other than people are realizing apartheid means nothing else
But oppression and exploitation to them
if Mr
Prince close contention is correct then why do we have these on the unrest in the countryside in the most backward areas of the country?
Mr.. Prince laws
Information is also correct, then why do we have these deposition of chiefs? Why do we have the government?
Agents moving around in the urban in the rural areas to find out. What is going on?
If the people who are so contented to audit within the net design to have so many agents?
Watching over them [I]
have had such hatred for every white man that [I] came across from
[the] earliest days that I could remember
but with the passing of years and having had
understanding of fundamental things in Life I
Have been able to overcome that
But I can assure [you] that that was one of the greatest struggles
That I had to undergo with myself
Mr.. Payton, it's a tall order [in] a big question, but if you can do it
How would you characterize the emotional climate of South Africa today?
Well, I think probably it's hotter than it's been for a long time in what way in regard to its race problem
Yeah
You know got to the relations between the groups I suppose the relations between the english-speaking and the afrikaans-speaking [rupe] are cold Mm-hmm
in view of the daily indignities
Humilities, and in some cases actual hardships economic and otherwise that the non-european is subjected to because of the apartheid laws
do you ever
Wonder at or a puzzle [that] a [non-European] can ever be civil to a white
Well that taught often occurs to me, Mr.. McCutcheon because you know we have many
non-European friends and sometimes you do wonder how they can
Go on liking you [you] [know]
Do you Mr. Payton Fear?
in the foreseeable future
Any widespread violence in South Africa?
Well, that's what everyone fears. It's not just me. It's no
I mean whether you're a white nationalist, or whether you're a black, [man], or whether you're english-speaking?
Whether you're an Indian, I think all of us have that fear [that] violence one day will it will be violent one day, Mr.
Payton I read a quote by you once not so long ago
In which if I can recall it?
You said you might hesitate
To rush forward to help an African injured on the street. Is that the essence of what you said you recall it? Oh?
Yes this letters quoted did not book drum by Anthony Simpson I
Think I I think I was 1948 I think [I] [what] a bit reticent and I heard pointer
I was really trying to make was that in this kind of race mad world in which we live that a white man
even if he [went] to the assistance might well hesitate
Before you did I think that that [might] you might find that in many parts of service the Southern states, [too]?
There's been much talk here
I underst and of passive resistance [as] a matter of actual fact however can the African the Indian or the colored in
his present economic state
financially afford a long period Of General strikes or passive resistance I
Would imagine no no you haven't got powerful trade unions you have built up great funds
But nevertheless. I mean there are significant things happening. You know you've heard of the bus Boycott. Yes. I have here in Johannesburg
There was an example where people by their determination
Forced the not only the bus companies, but also the government to retreat
Mr.. Payton, you [loved] this country very much despite. What's been happening here [for] the past Few years. What's happening here today?
How does it make you feel when you are aware that your beloved country is the subject of so much worldwide condemnation?
Well, I see I have so many friends in other countries, Mr.. [McCutchen], and I know that I don't
I'm not the subject of their condemnation
And I must say [that] makes it much easier for me [to] bear
See, but I understand well the reasons for this condemnation and much of it is justified
But it doesn't personally make me unhappy except I would say this that when I go overseas I
meet people who
Start condemning South Africa that very often I find myself my blood beginning to get warmer
And I find myself defending it even defending the government in fact in what one examples for [example]
Well, I can give you one very good example
[I'm] remember sitting next to a fellow at dinner in San Francisco, and he said to me this dr.
Milano's must be a very vicious old man
And I said the message you know that's not true
Actually, Dr.. Malone is in [his] own particular white world he is quite a
nice old gentleman
But when it comes into the world of rice when rice morality becomes his supreme morality which it is
That's what apartheid is. It's race morality then [he] will take any step whatsoever to ensure the supremacy of his own tea
In other words, Mr.. McCutchen if you make your own survival your supreme Moral value
And you're capable of almost anything even though you're a nice old man
Mr.. Pavements magnificent in this country is physically aren't there those who find it?
difficult if not impossible
To continue living in this climate of fear. [oh], yes, [Elisa]. I
Know what number of people who have finally decided to leave the country?
perhaps for their own sakes perhaps for the sake of their [children]
This question of apartheid has been placed so far as of [don] European is concerned so purely on a question of color
that theoretically if
black man should come into power in [South] [Africa]
Is it not possible that the Pendulum might swing the other way?
Is there any justification to fear that the white man would in truth be driven into the sea?
Well, that's a question that that lots of people ask and no one can answer Mr.. McCutcheon. I
would say that amongst the African people there are some of them who have under these ended under this present dispensation and the
dispensations before it
Will come to hate any kind of color discrimination whatsoever I?
Find it hard to believe. I mean I don't say the feeling of revenge will be entirely absent
But I find it hard to believe [that] they could set up a state in which their whole Aim would be to
discriminate against white people [I] find that difficult
Yes, master. Yes. Yes [laws]
ladies and gentlemen you know that the
Series of talks that we have been giving here have been talks
designed to describe to you how
government works
And you've had torques recently on
government and law in General and also a description of how the
parliamentary Machine works in South Africa
don't you think the Chairman that is the field of
cultivating the mind alert of the little things people is more work for the rebuttal to do their
time to come and try to cultivate the mind of the African people because I think
we're capable of
winded on your own self [if] not any advice from any angle Whatsoever
let us understand that here in South Africa and [in] fact in the whole of [Africa] we are dealing with the National Quest and
Africa is not very secure and disrespect
Nearly every country had had it let its national problems
And they are always solved by the people
according to the myth the needs of the majority of the people in the particular countries concerned I
Have at the present moment. We don't even have the right of self
Yes
It's printable we could define a term that's intrigued me since you started to use it you have said repeatedly that
The non-European is different from the European now in your mind is different synonymous with inferior
I think it is a generally accepted fact today that the
non-European is at the lowest stage of
Development and in honor of the Advanta European that does not mean [to] say [that] they are inherently inferior
circumstances amongst which they have grown up and
Grow their whole cultural background and everything their whole diet which would lead to physical physiological
Changes in their own nervous system would all lead to a general
Idea of the Inferiority amongst you in your compare original European with the European
But I do not believe that the non-European assets is inherently
Inferior is merely at a much lower state of development at the present better
but will they take up [their] -
Yes, boss. Yes
Yes, both
Yes, balls. Yes
yes, but
To you as a man of sensitivity and intelligence
Ever get used to a party and what it does to you
I'm a state not
Because it
continuously affronts me I
Am forced to be indignant about it. [I] cannot get used to it. I must resist it
you